>> Greg: TO THE UN THE PROUD
SWITCHING TO ANYTHING SO LOUD.
I WILL OUR MILITARY BE READY FO
THAT GETTING THE MEN A PETTY.
THEY'VE MARINE CORPS HAS
APPROVED YOU FROM CHANGES.
IF THIS ONE THING IT, IT'S
LETTING PEOPLE DO THEIR OWN
THING.
MARINES CAN GROW THEIR HALF TO
EDGES UP TO MAKE A NEATER
HAIRCUT AND THEY CAN WEAR BLACK
OR ALL OF SOX IN ADDITION TO
BROWN BUT THE EXCITING PART IS
FEMALE MARINES CAN WEAR TO TOE
NAIL POLISH COME ALL THAT MUST
BE CHECKED THE PINK OR BRET
BREAD THAT COMPLEMENT SKIN TONE.
THAT WILL MAKE FOR A SALUTE.
PLENTY OF PEOPLE ARE CALLING
THIS WOKE BS OR MAYBE IT'S JUST
CHANGING BUT THE TIMES.
SPEAKING OF CHANGES IN THE ARME
FORCES, THE ARMY HAS DROPPED IT
PLANS TO HAPPEN UP PHYSICAL
FITNESS TEST THAT IS GENDER AND
AGE NEUTRAL.
APPARENTLY MEN WERE PASSING THE
TEST OF THE HIGHER RATE THAN
WOMEN AND OLDER SIX SOLDIERS WH
WILL BE ALLOWED TO PASS WELL
MEETING SOME REDUCED STANDARDS.
BECAUSE AT THE BIOLOGICAL MALES
HAVE UP ADVANTAGE WHEN IT COMES
TO PHYSICAL STRENGTH.
GOOD THING THEY NEVER COMPETE
AGAINST WOMEN.
THAT WAS LIKE A CALL BACK, BRIAN
.
>> NICE JOB.
>> I KNOW IT IS EARLY IN THE
MORNING WHEN YOU DO YOUR SHOW.
>> AND A COUPLE HOURS.
>> I'M GOING TO GO TO YOU FIRST.
FIRST WE SHOULD ALL WE SALUTE
THE PEOPLE WHO AN LIST.
DOESN'T REALLY MATTER AT THIS
STOP.
IT IS WEIRD BECAUSE THESE
INSTITUTIONS, BUT NOW IT'S
PEOPLE SHAPING THE INSTITUTIONS.
>> REGULATIONS, ARE WE REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THEM PLAYING --
CHANGING FROM BLACK SOCKS TO AL
OF GREEN.
THE PHYSICAL FITNESS IS A
PROBLEM BECAUSE IF YOU WANT TO
WIN A WAR, PEOPLE I'VE GOT TO B
IN SHAPE.
I'M NOT SURE IF THIS IS A RESUL
OF THEM NOT BEING HIT TO FIND
QUALIFIED RECRUITS BECAUSE WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE COOL PEOPLE
AVAILABLE SETTING UP, THE
MAJORITY OF THEM CAN'T PASS UP
PHYSICAL FITNESS TEST SO THEY
LOWER THE STANDARDS.
THAT'S A BIG PROBLEM.
ENEMIES AROUND THE WORLD ARE
GOING, GREAT, THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA IS LOWERING BASIC
FITNESS STANDARDS.
WE WILL BE OKAY TO GO IN AGAINS
OUR MILITARY.
>> IT'S OKAY IF THE REST OF THE
PLAN IS DOING THE SAME THING BU
I'M NOT SURE THAT THEY WILL.
HERE IS THE COUNTERPOINT.
IS THIS REALLY A PROBLEM WITH
BASICALLY THE FUTURE OF WAR MY
COME DOWN TO JUST PUSHING
BUTTONS AND GROANS?
THAT IS PERFECT FOR ANYBODY
COMPOSITION.
EVEN BRIAN KILMEADE.
>> FIRST OF ALL, LEAVE HIM ALONE
.
HAVE YOU SEEN THE SIZE OF THE
BACKPACK THAT HE WALKS AROUND
WITH?
THAT'S A COMPLEMENT.
>> SO CLOSE.
YOUR BACKPACK GAME'S STRONG.
HERE IS THE PROBLEM, THE NFL,
NBA YOU HAVE TO CERTAIN LEVEL O
ATHLETIC SKILL.
THE ARMY AND MARINES AT THE SAM
WAY.
YOU ARE DEFENDING THE COUNTRY.
YOU ARE BEING DROPPED OFF IN TH
MIDDLE OF NOWHERE AND THIS GOOD
CHANCE YOU DON'T WANT TO HAVE A
FRENCH MANICURE WHEN YOU HIT TH
GROUND THAT CLEARS UP THE LIGHTS
.
I'M JUST SPECULATING.
AND I WILL BIT WOMEN IN THE
MARINES ARE DOING CARDINALS AND
JUMPING UP AND DOWN READ ABOUT
GETTING THEIR NAILS DONE.
AGAIN, THIS IS MORE OF THE SAME
OF THE EXTERNAL GROUP WOULD TRY
TO CHANGE THINGS INSTEAD OF
SAYING STOP BEING SO JUMPY AND
GET UP AND YOU MIGHT NOT GET IN
IF YOU ARE NOT IN SHAPE.
THAT STUFF IS TOO HARD.
IT HAS NOT BEEN TOO HARD TO MAK
IS THE SAFEST NATION IN THE
WORLD.
PEOPLE SACRIFICED AND WORKED TO
EARN THE RIGHT TO WEAR THE
UNIFORM.
PEOPLE JUST WANT THINGS GIVEN T
THEM NOW.
I SHOULD BE UP TO DEFEND MY
COUNTRY.
YOU SHOULDN'T UNTIL YOU TAKE
TIME AND ENERGY INTO THOSE JUMPS
.
GET A LINK YEAR AND GET THERE.
YOU KNOW, EVEN THOUGH YOU ARE
HAVE A VETERAN, DO YOU THINK
THAT YOU WOULD FAIL EVERY SINGL
TEST EITHER WITH THE LOWER
STANDARDS?
>> I KNOW IT.
I KNOW I WOULD.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO SEE YOU DO
ONE CHIN UP.
>> I BET SHE COULD.
>> THERE'S NO WAY.
THAT'S DISGUSTING.
>> ENOUGH OF THIS.
NEXT WEEK YOU'RE GOING TO PROVE
IT.
IF SHE DOESN'T JIM UP --
>> LOOK AT HER ARMS.
JUST LOOK AT HER.
LOOK HOW LONG IT IS.
>> IT'S REALLY LONG.
MY MOM THINKS THAT RITALIN
STUNTED MY GROWTH AND I'M LIKE
YOU PUT ME ON IT.
STRONG MUSCLES ARE GREAT.
SHE'S A PRAYING MANTIS.
I NEVER NOTICED IT.
>> UNLIKABLE MOSQUITO BITE ON
THAT STRING OF US SPAGHETTI HERE
.
>> I KNOW YOU CAN DO IT.
>> IT WOULD TAKE YOU AN HOUR.
>> I CAN'T DO IT.
AGAIN, I DON'T THINK THAT
MILITARY SERVICE IS FOR ME,
WHICH IS WHY I MARRIED A VETERA
SO I COULD BE A HALF VETERAN.
I DON'T THINK THIS DESCRIBES
ANYONE WITH THE MAIL PAINTING.
THE TRYING TO RECRUIT MORE WOME
AND I DON'T THINK IS A SINGLE
WOMAN THAT SAYS I WANT TO BE A
MARINE MARINE I CAN'T HAVE A
FRENCH MANICURE.
I DON'T THINK THAT DESCRIBES
ANYBODY.
THE TEST FOR MANICURE AGE, 63
REQUIRES A 2-MILE RUN AND ABOUT
23 MINUTES.
YOU FAIL THAT TEST?
>> I'M GREAT AT LONG DISTANCE.
>> A COUPLE OF THINGS.
HR CALLED AND YOU VIOLATED
EVERYTHING IN THE HANDBOOK.
PUT UP YOUR ARM AND LET ME JUDG
YOU.
I THINK I'M SOMEHOW AN
ACCOMPLICE JUST BY BEING ON THE
SET.
>> WE ARE GOING TO EDIT IT.
ARE YOU READY FOR THIS?
FOLLOW MAY BE DO YOU THINK
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A
MAN OF THE WOMAN, THEN YOU
CANNOT HAVE A PROBLEM WITH TWO
VERSIONS OF THAT TEST BECAUSE
WOMEN CAN'T COMPETE PHYSICALLY
WITH MEN AND IF YOU BELIEVE THA
IN THE A BLOCK, THEN YOUR B
BLOCK TO BE CONSISTENT SHOULD B
TOO QUICK SEPARATE TESTS.
>> I HAD ONE SECOND THINKING.
>> THAT'S ACTUALLY A GOOD POINT
AND THEN THAT GOES TO THE NEXT
POINT.
YOU HAVE TWO SEPARATE ARMIES?
>> THERE ARE SEPARATE DUTIES AN
SEPARATE UNITS OBVIOUSLY.
THE HIGHEST STANDARD IS MAYBE
THEY SHOULD.
>> YES, KAT'S LONG ARMS.
THEY ARE ALARMINGLY LONG FOR
SOMEONE OF MY HEIGHT.
>> Greg: YOU'VE BEEN BRADY
ABOUT YOUR LONG ARMS OF THE
FIRST TIME I'VE SEEN THAT.
>> GREAT COME IT IS THAT WORKIN
THE SAME WA